so you're already looking to be that ace
in the sky huh battlefield once closed
alpha is by no means a final product but
it does give us a solid start and
understanding what we can expect from
the air combat so strap in and flip on
that autopilot baby we're flight
schooling the basics swap between third
and first person views often when you're
making a tight turn switch the third
person to better grasp where that bogey
is heading first person will often block
your view only use it for precision
shots and also for free look scouting
your six o'clock and the field in
general spawning into a plane grants you
the repair ability and with BF ones new
contextual damage repairing in flight is
essential because depending on where you
received damage your planes movement is
affected ie if your tail rudder is shot
to hell the speed in which you pitch is
affected meaning you're outmatched in a
dogfight John I'm sorry they got us each
repair cycle grants you twenty-five
percent health but typically only one is
needed to get your movement back the
thing about repairing is it makes your
vehicle inoperable and you also can't be
taking any damage so now you have to
repairing rules one before you repair
make sure you're gaining altitude and
leveled out to avoid combat yet high
altitude and hug the outskirts of the
map oh and definitely make sure you're
not heading out of bounds contextual
damages also a factor when attacking
other planes it's best to spread your
hail of bullets around more or less in
general you're judging your bogey speed
and leading your shots if you've managed
to shoot up the Bombers left wings move
on once the damage is done to an aileron
or rudder that's it move your focus
elsewhere affect the planes different
parts of movement even though inflicting
wing and rudder damage is a plus for
real sweet spots are the engines pilot
seat and if he's really bugging ya the
rear gunner and once he's just sitting
duck be persistent if they know better
they'll try to shake you and repair back
to normal basic stuff right
planes in alpha you got three the bomber
is easily the best way to help your team
on the ground only problem is it's
probably the only plane that is utterly
desperate for Gunners but hey you got no
Gunners just do yourself you are a giant
sky crawling bullet sponge and
practically every single person in the
match can see that so stay high in the
sky in order to stay away from the
anti-air gun range and other ground fire
there you drop two types of payloads two
big bombs or a cluster of little box
these kind of speak for themselves big
bombs for armor and then mop up with the
clusters which are also best for
carpeting infantry this third ability i
believe is recon i'm not quite sure let
me know in the comments if you know i'm
sorry the fighter to simply put is an
air-to-air combat plane your duty is to
defend your bombers and take enemy air
down compared to other planes the
triplanes gun has great distance and
minor bullet drop making it prime as a
hit-and-run flying sniper it's superior
speed and agility make up Brooks weak
health so when taking down bombers and
attack planes attacking from below and
above is your best bet you're trying to
avoid a Gunners line-of-sight the attack
plane is your middle man all in all it's
your default and you can do all right
without a gunner and your grenade bombs
allow for some ground support however
these grenade bombs are by no means
powerful in fact it's probably best to
just hunt infantry in armored cars do
consider gaining much altitude and dive
bombing doing this allows your grenades
to group up inflicting more damage in
one area you're also rocking spotting
flares so don't forget to launch these
over capture points they do help and
then there's the elephant in the room
just listen for that foghorn because
this cruise ship has arrived to the
Bahamas it's the behemoth if it's open
do take that pilot seat its third person
view isn't very helpful so gauge your
surroundings in first person and then
switch to your bomb sites and get busy
your bomb cooldown is consistent meaning
the longer you wait the more bombs you
can potentially drop at once your goal
is to move to capture points that are
being attacked and just bomb baby and
then Gunners if you have a full word
behemoth you can decimate the entire
town top two turrets work the skies and
foreground you got to slide Turks and
the money spot the five-seat has the
front 180 view best seen the house and
as far as taking down the enemy behemoth
Brown turrets and planes aren't hitting
the blimp portion but the gondolas knock
an enemy gondola out and you knock out
the Gunners inside it as well as doing
overall damage to this beast and a side
note if you're piloting a doom behemoth
destined to crash why not position its
carcass over an enemy capture point use
the behemoth wreckage and mold the map
to your liking
well that's it for this starter guide
for air combat again this is only an
alpha meeting all of this is technically
up for change but if you have any
pointers or questions feel free to leave
a comment and be sure to subscribe for
more battlefield one coverage thanks for
watching